the apparent ease with which the FBI was
able to monitor Carter page without his
knowing it should have the rest of us
asking when is it acceptable to spy on
US citizens has the norm become that
it's always acceptable for the US
government to spy on its own people
Glenn Greenwald rights for the intercept
he spent a lot of time covering the
Americans surveillance state and he
joins us tonight Glenn thanks for coming
up great to be with Tucker so I should
in the interest of honesty note the
obvious irony which is the Congress
Republican Congress just reauthorized
the law that made this possible in the
first place and did so with very little
public debate on the subject and so that
raises kind of a more basic question
which is why is this question when and
how and for what reason the US
government spies on its own people why
is that so rarely debated in public it's
a great question I mean it's the reason
why Edward Snowden decided to risk going
to prison because he was so concerned
that this huge massive surveillance day
was being constructed in secret directed
not just at foreign adversaries but
inward domestically at the American
people without anybody knowing about it
and so he came forward because he was so
concerned that Congress and then the
Senate never debated it never discussed
what the parameters are and the irony is
that we've had Democrats on the one hand
spending the last year warning that
Trump is this lawless tyrant endangering
democracy we've had the Republicans
saying the deep state is endangering
democracy by abusing its power and yet
Democrats the leadership anyway not the
majority got together with the
Republican majority including Devon
Nunez who authored the memo today and
just not more than two weeks ago voted
to increase lying power and block all
safeguards on how it's used so it's
really incredible now to watch this
debate unfold well it's it's actually
almost nauseating
and as I said totally ironic so you know
a lot about how this works what week
what is legal and what is not legal what
does the US government need to show to a
judge or a series of judges in order to
get permission to legally spy on a US
citizen so in order to target a US
citizen the way that they targeted
Carter page which means essentially that
they're going to listen to all of his
phone calls read his emails
him digitally they need to demonstrate
to a FISA Court which is a court that
meets in secret with just the Justice
Department president that there's
probable cause to believe that he's an
agent of either a foreign government or
a terrorist organization so they
convinced a judge obviously a FISA Court
judge that there's probable cause to
believe that Carter Paige is an agent of
the Russian government
how often are those requests turned down
do we know
almost never
there's something like a ninety-nine
point eight percent approval rate the
FISA Court is a joke in terms of whether
or not it provides real safeguards or
oversight for how the NSA and the FBI
can spy on American citizens they
basically rubber stamp whatever it is
that's put in front of them and so
Democrats used to say that a lot but
when George Bush and Dick Cheney got
caught spying on Americans of that going
to the FISA Court the booed the argument
of the bush ministration was it's so
burdensome and Democrats said well it's
so easy they never turn you down and now
Democrats are trying to say oh it's a
very rigorous process that's not they
almost never ever say no yeah
Glenn Greenwald who's been a brave voice
from the left on the subject for many
years thank you for that I appreciate it
good to be with Tucker